And finally, new rule.
As an Ivy League graduate
who knows the value
of a liberal education,
I have one piece of advice
for the youth of America.
Don't go to college.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS, APPLAUDS)
And if you absolutely
have to go,
don't go to an elite college,
because as recent events
have shown,
it just makes you stupid.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
There are few, if any,
positives to come out
of what happened in Israel.
But one of them
is opening America's eyes
to how higher education
has become indoctrination
into a stew of bad ideas.
Among them,
the simplistic notion
that the world is a binary place
where everyone is either
an oppressor or oppressed.
In the case of Israel,
oppressors being
babies and bubbes.
The same students
who will tell you
that words are violence
and silence is violence
were very supportive
when Hamas terrorists
went on a rape and murder
rampage worthy of the Vikings.
They knew where to point
the fingers, at the murdered,
and then it was off
to ethics class.
(CHUCKLING)
-Now--
-(APPLAUSE)
Now I recognize that a certain
amount of foolishness
is expected of college kids.
But, mixing Jägermeister
and tomato juice
isn't the same
as siding with terrorists.
(CHUCKLING)
Thirty-four student groups
at Harvard signed a letter
that said the apartheid regime
is the only one to blame,
proving they don't know
what constitutes apartheid.
They don't know much
of anything, actually.
But it doesn't deter them
from having an opinion.
They've convinced themselves
Israel is the most
repressive regime in history
because they have
no knowledge of history,
or even a desire to know it.
And actual history
doesn't come up
in their intersectionality
of politics and gender queer
identities class.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
Now to be fair, at least
five of the student groups
have rescinded what they signed,
saying they didn't
read the letter closely.
(CHUCKLING)
And they promised
not to make that mistake again
after they graduate
and start running the world.
(LAUGHTER)
-But--
-(APPLAUSE)
I actually believe them,
that they didn't read
the letter closely.
I think they scanned it,
said it was blaming Israel,
and went back to surfing TikTok.
(CHUCKLING)
Because college life today
is a day spa
combined with a North Korean
re-education camp.
To daycare center
with a meal plan,
except that toddlers
can fire the adults.
The fact that
college presidents,
who usually love
to speak out about anything,
couldn't find their voice
to condemn the worst attacks
since the Holocaust
says a lot about who
really controls colleges.
And why,
if ignorance is a disease,
Harvard Yard
is the Wuhan wet market.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
It's not that colleges
didn't always have
professors with radical beliefs.
I know,
I used to sell them weed.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
But the reason why
despising Israel
became pretty much a requirement
of the American left
is colleges.
Elite colleges,
the mouth of the river,
from which this and all manner
of radical left, illiberal--
yes, illiberal, nonsense flows.
Supporting all-Black,
that is, segregated dorms,
segregated
graduation ceremonies
and orientation programs,
which occur on hundreds
of campuses, is illiberal.
So is the racism
against Asian applicants,
and chasing speakers
off of campus.
(SCOFFS)
When the First Amendment
watchdog group
Foundation for Individual
Rights and Expression
began ranking colleges,
based on their commitment
to free speech and inquiry,
Harvard came in dead last.
There's only one set of
acceptable opinions on campus,
and it's policed hard.
The old dorm room
bull sessions. (CHUCKLES)
It's less risky shooting
the shit in scientology.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
John--
John Stewart Mill wrote that,
To which today's
college students respond,
"He and his are cis pronouns..."
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
"...that commit violence against
queer and BIPOC communities,
so who cares what
Jon Stewart Mill says,
whoever he is.
(CHUCKLING)
"Oh, and Thomas Jefferson
was a slave holder.
He might have done
some other stuff,
but it wasn't on the test."
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
Elite schools should
no longer be called elite.
Just stay expensive.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
Which may be why they breed
a particular brand
of detestable graduate.
A personality type that does
not emerge from Chico State.
(LAUGHTER)
Sure, they occasionally
turn out someone decent.
But for every Barack Obama,
there are two Josh Hawleys.
(CHUCKLING)
The former debate team jerk-off
who had no friends,
that no one likes today,
and yet somehow manages to win
a statewide popularity contest.
Box-checking brown-nosers who
don't actually believe anything,
except that tricking
stupid people's fun.
-That's--
-(APPLAUSE)
That's why it is so repulsive
when they pander for votes
from Mama June and
the flat-earthers, because...
(SCOFFS)
"They just hate elitists."
Yeah. Look at these
truck-driving he-men from
the tool aisle at Sam's Club.
Vivek Ramaswamy,
Yale and Harvard.
Ron DeSantis, Yale and Harvard.
Ted Cruz, Princeton and Harvard.
Pat Robertson, George W. Bush,
Tom Cotton, Mike Pompeo,
Bill O'Reilly, Steve Bannon,
Jared Kushner,
most of the Supreme Court.
There's a special magic
that links Harvard-types
and being utterly
face-punchable.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
And some, I assume,
are good people.
(LAUGHTER)
And while it may seem like
these men, men like these,
and the kids who signed
the Harvard letter
have nothing in common,
actually, I think they do.
They all came out
of an asshole factory.
-So--
-(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
So... (CHUCKLES)
To the older folks, I say,
college today is not
the college you remember.
And to the younger people,
I say, don't, don't do it.
You don't need four years
and a lifetime of crippling debt
to learn to hate America,
when you can just watch
five minutes of Selling Sunset.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
If your parents have 300 grand
they absolutely need
to flush down the toilet,
put it in crypto, or buy a van,
go to a National Park
and feed yourself to a bear.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
Because any legacy dipshit
can go to Penn,
but a bear,
that's hard to get into.